so marc lamont hill is interviewing
christopher ruffo and he asks the
question
if whiteness is not always a bad thing
what do you like about being white and
if i were to say to you right now
christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know again again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
but can you can you indulge me in
indulge me for once
just we're running out of time indulge
me for a minute i understand you see it
as as all these things but
you surely recognize that the world sees
you as white you know the world reads
you as white
and if you were to ask me some things i
like about being black i could talk
about cultural norms i could talk about
tradition i could talk about
the kind of commonalities i feel around
the diaspora if i were to ask you what
particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be
name name something positive that you
like about being white
well sure i i you know i'll i'll answer
with uh with that a thing there
you're telling me you're making
strongmen about things that are ascribed
to whiteness that you think are
wrongfully ascribed to whiteness i'm
saying if whiteness isn't a negative
thing
and there's something that you actually
and that whiteness actually shouldn't be
constructed as all negative
name something positive about being that
you believe is positive about being
white
again i i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness
oh man this is a good question people
are
attacking mark lamont hill for asking
this question but it's a brilliant
question
not because it stumps chris ruffo
actually the fact that chris ruffo can't
answer the question
is the same reason why mark lamont hill
did answer the question
and it's just a fact of our culture now
you are not allowed to
say that there is anything good about
being
white and likewise you're not really
allowed to say that there's anything bad
about being black
you're not allowed to say any that
there's anything about particularly good
about white
culture you're not even really allowed
to say that there is a white culture
people who attack
white people are allowed to say there's
a white culture but people who are white
are not allowed to acknowledge that
there is any such thing as a white
culture
and it's not just a trick question
because one of the tr
the trick that mark lamont hill could
have thrown on chris rufo here
is he could have said what's y what's
good about being white you're you're
saying whiteness is not purely negative
okay so what's good about being white
and then chris ruffo says i don't know
whatever you know
lobster rolls or something and and mark
lamont hill could have said how dare you
you racist
there's being any race is neither good
nor bad
it's just you're racist you think but
mark does not say that he says
look i'm black i think there's some good
things about being black
this is some cultural norms some
commonalities he's using really vague
terms you'll notice
but he says yeah i think there are good
things about being black specifically
about being black so
what are some good things about being
white but you're not allowed to answer
that
you're not allowed to answer that but i
guess i guess
if you're allowed to say it about every
other race and i guess i guess
i guess you should be allowed to say it
about being white right chris chris's
impulse is to say there's no such thing
as white people but marc lamont hill is
saying no there is
and i'm your skin looks different than
my skin
whether it's a social construct or it's
a biological essential characteristic
there is such a thing as white people so
you tell me i'm telling you that there
is such a thing as white people and it's
totally negative
so you tell me there's something
positive and i don't know i guess if i
had to answer the question what would i
say
what is what is good about being white
uh
a lower risk of sickle cell anemia
that's pretty good
right i get are we not allowed to say
that's a good thing to be at a lower
risk of
sickle cell anemia beyond that i don't
know
some history i don't know there's some
one does take pride in history
not pride in the sense of you know
excessive love of one's own excellence
not pride you know that
that goeth before destruction and a
haughty spirit before to fall but one
does take
some satisfaction in the history of
one's community this is true
actually mark lamont hill sort of
alludes to it himself so sure yeah i
think that's true
that's right and conservatives i think
ignore that or deny that at their own
peril we're conservatives obviously we
like some things about history
what else i like sockless loafers is
that part of white culture i get kind of
yeah i guess so
i like um what else do i like like the
stiff upper lip
you know in english culture this is not
true of
all white white cultures i guess you'd
have to get a little more specific
the italians are not exactly known for
the stiff upper lip they're a little
more emotive
but the brits are known for this
they don't make a big show of their
emotions all the time they're not always
whining and screaming unless they're
prince hairy
they push things down a little bit and
just go on and have a little manly
courage that's good
is that good am i going to get cancelled
for answering mark lamont hill's
question
i know that that he's using this as a
kind of
rhetorical tactic but it actually shows
you something very important
which is everybody else
has a racial consciousness and this is
encouraged except for
white people and there's a trick even to
this i mean so there was a
pew research survey that measured racial
consciousness
measured it among black people hispanics
asians and whites
every one of those three groups said
that their race the first three groups
said that their race was somewhat or
very important to their sense of
identity
among black people it was quite high and
it was over 70 percent and among
hispanics and asians it was over 50
do you know what the number was for
white people 15
1-5 white people have basically
no racial identity fine by me i guess i
count myself in that group
of white people who don't think about
race very much at all there's a reason
for this
a practical reason which is in countries
where you're the majority
you're you're just not going to be that
aware of race so it was perfect
perfectly natural i think if i were
walking around tibet
i think i'd probably be more aware of my
race than if i were walking around
kansas city however there's another
reason here which is that
anti-racism is an idea that only exists
in white countries if there's no
anti-racism in china okay there's no
anti-racism
in i don't know namibia or
right there's no anti-racism in
saudi arabia
anti-racism the idea that there are more
important things in life
and race actually doesn't really matter
that much at all in politics
that is a western idea and it comes from
countries that
at least historically are white
countries so that's
part of the trick here as well you're
not allowed to say it but see how
unstable that is
see how many contradictions there are
see how uncomfortable
that question line of questioning was
because what mark lamont hill is showing
is that in our new racial caste system
there is
one set of rules for non-white people
and there's another set of rules for
white people
it's this this racial politics is a
totally rigged
game and
it's very effective for the radical life
this is why the radical left is focused
very much on on racial politics
hey stop before you go just one second
subscribe ring the bell like it
subscribe head on over by the way to
apple podcast google play spotify
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give you all
sermon about it
okay i'm not gonna go for hours and
hours it's very simple
do that and you will get the
notifications when we have more content
out there
see them
you